Over the love-hateyears,
I've had a love-hate relationship
with I-cord edging for my knitting.
Sometimes it looks good.
And other times, not so much.
So I often will turn to crochet.
Now, I recently discovered why. I've never
paid attention to the direction
that I'm slipping.
OK, let's start at the beginning.
I-cord is created by casting on a few
stitches and knitting in one direction.
And slipping in the other.
By carrying the working yarn
with the slip and I-cord forms.
You can create a finished edge for your
knitting by joining the edge
of your knitting to some I-cord.
Pick up the edge loops and hang them one
at a time on the end needle of the cord.
And knit cord and edge
strand together to join.
Here's my big discovery. In this example,
I'm slipping to the left.
I'll pick up the edge
loop and join my I-cord.
It creates a beautiful edge.
Looks great on both sides.
Next, I'll reverse the slip setting.
I'm still picking up along the left hand
edge here, but I am slipping to the right.
Now, it may be difficult to see in these
images, but there is quite a bit
of difference between the two methods.
My I-cord join is so much better when I
slip in the direction that I'm picking up.
Mystery solved.
I may just start using I-cord again.
Now, if you don't believe me,
give it a try.
You may be as surprised as I was.